Welcome everybody to another zoom call. I apologize for my voice is a little scratchy today
but
Reminder to everybody that you go to your member site the member site for our full cancer patients
Is where you'll find everything all the recordings to the zoom calls are on there. It's got tabs to a whole bunch of different stuff
Handed announcements everything is on the member site
so
Pretty much everything you want to know is on the member site. All right first question in the last two weeks by
CA 153 to Remarker has decreased by 47 points. That's great news
But by alcohol and phosphatase many times that's breathing at ALK on your comprehensive metabolic profile
Alcohol and phosphatase went from 82 to 111
High starts at 104. So remember the lab values for high are going to be different depending on lab
Many of the
Access lab and lab core I think it's over 120 is considered high
Optimal range really anything over 100 is considered high
So yes 111 is high
Right calcium went from 10.9 to 11.1
Okay, so that you know, there's a margin of error there so
Pretty much you could say that that stayed the same my question is what is considered high alcohol and phosphatase and how long could it stay there?
well
Understand you have lab ranges and optimal ranges. So the lab ranges can vary typically high level or optimal range or functional range is 100
Some people would even say a little bit less than that
So 111 is
High, but also you have to take a consideration of what can be normal for a person
Let's say you've had multiple labs
Past and your alkaline phosphatase in the past has always ranged on the low end of normal
So then
You know any elevation even though it might still be lower than 100 let's say it was 98
But you always ranged at the low end of normal
You'd have to consider consider that that's high. So you're looking at when you're looking at lab values
You're looking at previous labs done
Which way is the lab trending and how is it correlated to other different values in the test?
Would alkaline phosphatase elevates
Along with calcium the first thing you'd think of at least it would give you a clue
That the elevation is due to boldly destruction
Because elevated alkaline phosphatase can be from multiple different reasons if you have irritation to the liver
From taking a medication. Let's say if I'm in this all or I'm remected
That can elevate alkaline phosphatase but typically would spare
calcium
If alkaline phosphatase and calcium go up together
You'd think it would be coming from bone remember alkaline phosphatase can become from tissue destruction
Especially in bone
And especially if we know that there's men's to bone. So
What is high? We're going to say there's been people with alkaline phosphatase in the 300
600s go to six with acute liver distress
But the point is is that you you want to be looking at the trend
If a person is thinking that let's say they're on vendusol and or Ivermectin
And it is working to decrease the cancer. Let's say in this case two markers are going down
alkaline phosphatase is going up could it be because of the continue use of the fendusol it could be
Is that at a is 111 at a danger mark where we have to cut the fendusol and Ivermectin?
I would say no
The less the person's normal alkaline phosphatase prior to getting cancer was like 28 or so
low number
That would be lab low but
um
No, I would say you're safe still
You're not at a danger for a liver shutdown at 111
Continuation of that question it seems like that Ivermectin at the fendusol I'm working more so that Ivermectin since I was taking fendusol a month
Oh before alone in my c8 9 15 3 and c8 27 29 2 markers went from 100 to 200 during that month
I don't want liver damage
Want to disrupt by progress either
Could the higher alkaline phosphatase be for the bones meds?
And also a lagging indicator yes both those like I said both those could be true
Have lab schedule for another two weeks or no and that's really the key
I know a lot of people don't like to go and get labs
There's a cost to getting labs if you can't get your insurance to pay for them
But seeing them more frequently would be more beneficial
And turkey tail mushrooms be taken by someone who is allergic to mushrooms
I didn't know if it was from a different component of the mushrooms that
caused a problem
so
If you're allergic to
My first question would be how do you know you're allergic to mushrooms
Well, I break out when I eat mushrooms
So I can't eat mushrooms or I get an anaphylactic shock when I have eat mushrooms
Well, if you have anaphylaxis from eating mushrooms and I would stay away from any mushroom pros
Products whatsoever because you have an IGE reaction
If you break out or you get a tummy ache when you eat mushrooms or some doctor tested you with kinesiology
Or you did an IGE food panel test at one point in time
And you came up positive for mushrooms that you've been eliminating mushrooms from that from those scenarios
I would say
No, go ahead and take the medicinal mushroom products
Your IGG IGE antibody tests if you had them done in the past and that showed positive for mushrooms that can change
You know within a couple months of you eliminated mushrooms. So
Many times people will do a food sensitivity panel and it will become positive and something so that they'll stay off of it the rest of their life
I my mother-in-law was like that. I remember she said she can't eat walnuts
Why can't you eat walnuts because a doctor told her when she was like 15 that she couldn't eat walnuts
And now she's 70 years old and she still not had a walnut
Well, the chance that you're sensitive to walnuts
You know even after a few months of stop eating walnuts is pretty slim to zero
So but she was very much a rule follower and she followed that rule even
So I think foolishly and to her
Demise because she didn't get to enjoy walnuts
There was many other things that she stayed away from because some doctor told her when she was in her teens that she was allergic to something
Food sensitivities can come and go
especially if you stay off that that food
And more importantly if you're talking there's a difference between an ige reaction food sensitivity like a peanut allergy
ige reaction and a food sensitivity where you react to a food ige
She sensitivities
gluten would probably be the only
um
exception of that
People can be off gluten a hundred percent for 10 years and you still do food panel on them. They still show positive
uh antibodies. So um
Hope that helps that question
Next question what are your thoughts on collagen for a woman with hormone positive breast cancer?
Is there a brand you recommend if it's safe to take?
Typically collagen is not a problem
for most cancers
um
And you know, there's multiple brands out there that are good worth a molecular has a good
brand product called collagen
um
That's a good product that seems to be quite popular in people like it
Is there a reason to take micro poll
Product and biotoxin binder in the afternoon
uh
As instructors in my protocol sometimes it's hard to get it in until evening
But I didn't want to miss the best window for effectiveness
Well, you know, if you know, you get it in when you can get it in, you know, just uh
The information and studies that have been out there using binders taking them and the afternoon
Seems to be considered best
protocol, but
Everybody's different and not everybody can do it that way. So do it the best way. You can't don't be too crazy in all the moment
Let me wait over the toxins
tests I registered
Super high for one used as a flame return it. I can't recall the name
At the moment
I've been racking my brain trying to figure out how I got so much of it since we don't have any newer carpeting
or a new car etc
I get my hair colored and a beauty shop. Do you know if there could be a connection there
You have any info on your website about safe hair color
You that would be a good question. I don't know that I have any information on our website
You could search it hair color. I don't know that I have any information on our website about that
Could there be that chemical that is used in spotted flavor terms in hair dye?
I don't it but anything's possible
What else could have flame retarded chemicals in it? Well pretty much any clothing
Any furniture any fabric
It's gonna have flame flame retarded chemicals in it. So
Any of those things so you all your new clothing
Is gonna have that so
Unless you're buying organic cotton clothing
Most likely it's gonna be sprayed with flame retarded
You can do a search on that chemical and find look for google search and search sources
And you could get a pretty good idea where it could be hidden in something as well
Would oxy cell oxy cell is is a glutathione cream
From
A company that we don't carry their products anymore because they won't let us sell them on our store
Apex energinics
Would that be something to apply occasionally to the breast area for somebody with breast cancer?
No, no, so
Glutathione is
Not something that we would recommend in general to somebody
With cancer period and if you go to
Back to our website and you search
Harnessing oxidative stress to kill cancer
That will help you understand the process of
Trying to not use antioxidants in
Treating cancer
I know there's a difference in subapidium in there in that
I know we have a lot of patients that come to us initially and they're on they went to their their natural path
They're their chiropractor and we're giving a protocol for their cancer and much of the protocol included
Hydose antioxidants alpha low-pec acid, you know
Glutathione products
Glutathione precursors SOD catalyst
These are all antioxidants and
In the thought process that well oxidative stress causes cancer
So we need to decrease oxidative stress well
You haven't listened to me very long if you haven't heard me talk about
the
Bros and cons of oxidative stress with cancer. So
There's multiple blog posts on glutathione and cancer using glutathione with cancer using oxidative stress
Stimulators to help
Increase oxidative stress for those with cancer. So I would say, you know
Look at that look on our website about that. But the answer is quick answer. No, do not do that
I did retesting a few months ago and started some new supplements for anxiety and depression. It really hasn't
I really haven't noticed a huge difference
I am on a lot of supplements and it's very costly. So I just
Want to be on supplements and focus on the cancer
What would be your recommendations? Well, if I put you on adaptogens
uh and
Things specifically for the anxiety and depression. They're not working then by all means don't spend the money and buy it again
Now understand
When you're on a supplement like an adaption core
That it could take a while for it to kick in so but if you've been on it a couple months
And it's really not helping then by all means maybe just phase off of that
Work on the parasympathetic nervous system look up parasympathetic nervous system
Stimulation on our
On the member site and it's on the stuff fighting cancer course and it's on our website
You want to stimulate the parasympathetics to help calm the anxiety
Also on them blog posts and on the member site you'll see
vagal
Cradial nerve 10 is the vagus nerve also called vagal vagal nerve stimulation
So you want to stimulate cradle nerve 10 that is your main parasympathetic nervous system stimulation
So you want to work on that
Then they just get back it used just your cancer supplements and stay on those
Is it bad to pause the rife or if
Or if I can't finish a ball one night
Oh, so if you're saying
You know the night program is nine hours long and you got had to get up in seven and a half hours should you pause it?
No, don't pause it just let it run out or just turn it off and start the next night
With the next program. No, don't don't worry about that
Not everybody gets all their night
timed out every night you just don't so that's why every night is a little bit different
You know, there's a lot of the same frequencies at each night. I flip flop them so that
I realize you're getting up to one of the mastermind different times you you know you get
Interrupted you have to wake up early. So that's why I do that
So that you're not missing out any frequencies. Don't pause it. Just let it time out or turn it off and start the next night
the next day
one of your thoughts on chlorine dioxide
detox
I have several videos on these before that I've answered this question
Multiple times or this question always gets us in trouble
So we won't be able to post this video on YouTube or they will literally shut down our channel. It's funny how they can
scan with AI and find
Video on chlorine dioxide that some little teeny pukey a little clinic
posted on their teeny little YouTube channel
You know, and they'll find it within an hour or they'll block our channel
But they can't stop pornography. It's just literally blows my mind the evil that's in this world
But such is the case
What are my thoughts on chlorine dioxide detox? Well, there's a much said and much promised with chlorine dioxide in that chlorine dioxide
Circles
Dr. Jim Humble
What MMS on the map years ago and
Though I think there's much benefit to it when we used to treat line patients. We used MMS all the time
I think it can be extremely beneficial to kill pathogens
That are difficult to kill it has side effects
But I also think it is way overhyped and quite honestly between you and me
I think dr. Jim Humble was a sort of a snake oil salesman
So he when you start claiming that something is the panacea of all disease. I think
You know, you're frigid on
That as you know a label on your
Your coat because it's just it's just not true chlorine dioxide can be toxic
It can cause toxic issues. It can cause inflammation. It can cause damage to
To tissues
Certainly can cause oxidative stress, which not necessarily isn't necessarily a bad thing with cancer patients
But it doesn't spare healthy cells. So whereas okay, so we're trying to
Increase oxidative stress with the cancer patient. Let's say we're using high dose curriculum. That's an example
High dose curriculum will cause oxidative stress to cancer cells and thereby help tip them over and cause death to a cancer cell
But it does not cause oxidative stress to a healthy cell. It's spare as healthy cells
Versus chemotherapy causes oxidative stress to cancer cells and can kill cancer cell
But does not spare healthy cells and can cause cancer elsewhere in the body and can kill other cells
So it you have to be careful in the dosage so you don't kill the patient before you kill the cancer
Same thing with chlorine dioxide. It is a drug. It's not a natural supplement
So it doesn't spare healthy cells. So I am not a fan of using chlorine dioxide with cancer
But by a fan of using chlorine dioxide with lime disease sure it can be extremely beneficial
But you have to go slow with it
Questions from the chat if I run a short program
The first part of the night and then start my cancer program is the last two hours of that program the same as the first seven hours
So it's the last two hours of my overnight program the same as the first seven hours. No
No, no your your night programs are running different frequencies
You know throughout the nights. I mean typically I
Typically the maximum amount of time on any given frequency is only three minutes
so
Yeah, so it's different going through that night
So if you're missing three you know a couple hours every single night
You know, there's nothing wrong with doing that for a period of time, but that's not best practice long-term
Also, how close should I have the rifball to my body during sleeping should I be concerned about EMF exposure
There's no EMFs that are coming out of the bulb
So you don't need to worry about that. I made a video on EMFs coming from your computer
I used the EMF meter to measure EMFs coming from your rif computer
And that was just about zero
The only EMFs that I did have coming from the computer is when I connected it to the internet
So when you have your computer on airplane mode like you're supposed to
You really shouldn't be getting any EMFs and when you hit run on your computer and then you close it so it goes to sleep
It's not producing any EMFs
So there isn't any EMF issues how close should you have the rifball to your body while you're sleeping
Is as close as you possibly can you should stungle with it if possible
If oh, I can't do that. It just drives me crazy
Okay, then leave it six inches away. Oh, I just I can't I roll over and I roll on it. Can I leave it 12 inches away?
Yeah, we can but every 12 inches that you move away from the object you're decreasing the benefit of the frequency
So yeah, if you're doing much better and you're in full remission, you can keep it 12 inches away. That's just fine
But like I've always recommended and I know some physicists might get out and say now
You're gonna still get just as much treatment if your 24 inches away
Then you are then if it's right next to you
Maybe but for me, I just think the closer it is to your
To the source of the injury. I think the better it's gonna be
Well
Any other questions
Okay, just to get another reminder use the member site
There's a lot of information on the member site
Use our website search our web our website for anything if you're like I need to answer to this question a sap
search our website
Go to our video site you can see our video site on the member site and on the website go to the video site
We have thousands of videos
Search the video site
most likely I made a video about it. So
Look at that and you can find information
Before the zoom call if you what I love answering your questions, so don't get me wrong
But most of them you can find them before you have to wait until Wednesday
Question came in what do you recommend for a lymphatic system cleansing
Well, there's you know, you can't technically cleanse your lymphatic system
You want to help move your lymph
Um, that's what you want to do. So let's
We're gonna refer you back to our website and search lymphatic search lymph
And you'll see a bunch of information on how to help move lymph
Uh, the best way to move lymph is motion exercise contraction of muscles. That's the best way to move lymph
All right with that we will bid ado till next week though that we're praying for all of you and we cherish your prayers for us
and um
God bless and keep praying for each other. Bye bye